a technician confirms that the tracks
and pads are correctly located a
conveyor then takes one of the panels
into a machine that precisely positions
a metal mesh stencil over it an
automated squeegee spreads solder paste
onto the circuit boards through the open
areas of the stencil the solder paste
will act as glue for over 100 tiny
electrical components next the circuit
boards receive those electrical
components the parts include
microprocessors sensors and memory chips
then the circuit boards head into an
oven with several different heating and
cooling zones as they travel through
these zones the soldering particles melt
to bond the components to the circuit
boards here a technician positions them
under probes the probes descend and load
software into the micro processors this
brings them to life and enables them to
control all of the board's functions
another technician trims and cuts the
panels using circular saws she then
punches out the four round circuit
boards and transfers them to a tray that
has an electrically conductive surface
the technician places a buzzer mechanism
behind a backlight
she transfers the two of them to the
reverse side of a display screen she
places a plastic framework on top and
she inserts rubber connectors in it the
next assembler inserts the circuit board
into the digital display unit in the
next stage of production the worker
removes any dust particles from the
screen using blasts of compressed air
she snaps the dive computer module into
a tough plastic case that's designed to
withstand a lot of water pressure she
cleans a glass faceplate and places it
over the digital screen this faceplate
will protect the screen from water the
next part is a metal bezel it surrounds
the faceplate and will be used to secure
to the casing she flips the assembly
around and screws the bezel to the case
from the back
she inserts the computer battery into a
titanium backplate she then installs the
battery assembly in the back of the
module and secures it with screws